I am actually quite prorogue many women
have a soft spot for my great aunt cause
sh-1 tease but not in that way what I am
not in favor of is any Prime Minister
Pro Rogan or suspending parliament in
order to ram through a No Deal without a
confirmatory vote in the Commons
this would make a mockery of all the
brexit as arguments that leaving the EU
would restore us our sovereignty and
allow Parliament to take back control
what utter guff
businesswoman an activist gina miller is
absolutely correct to reassemble her
winning legal team to stop this
she said it a million times she's not
anti brexit she's never tried to stop
brexit for what she is very very Pro is
Parliament having a say in what happens
and a vote on the deal as we are still
just a parliamentary democracy a PM Pro
Rogan would constitute an abuse of power
she says and I agree we are the home of
the mother of Parliament's not some
Banana Republic run by a tin-pot
dictator MPs who respect mother should
support MS Miller well I actually think
that what is the abuse of power is the
fact that Parliament I've done
everything possible to have prevented us
from actually executing properly exiting
the European Union that's what I
personally see as the abuse of power and
I think that the fact we're in this
situation is so appalling I have no
words or time to get into it but in
terms of in terms of the Gina Miller
latest threat of the case the question
needs to be is it legal that whoever the
next prime minister is can actually
provoke Parliament and if the answer to
that is yes then I don't even understand
why there should be a legal challenge
and it's that that is kind of confusing
me do I think that we should provoke
Parliament take away the legal aspect to
get no deal through it wouldn't be my
preferred option but I think it's
fundamentally wrong that
MPs would try and block an ER deal
because actually what I think should
happen is that we should be preparing
for properly preparing for and No Deal
brexit and if that's what we have to do
then that's what we have to do and this
was just stopping and blacking is wrong
I don't disagree that I mean Jonathan
sumption wrote a piece explained setting
all this out prorogation is just a
normal procedure that's become very
exciting because it could be the one
device
the government has within its power at
the moment in order to get through no
deal without having to get through the
last hurdle that gina miller said to us
which was that parliament could had to
vote the deal through in some way Greg
what do you think John mojo was quite
inspired he said yes I think the idea of
pierogi Parliament is utterly and
totally unacceptable from any British
parliamentarian or Democrat if that were
to happen I think there will be a queue
of people who would seek judicial review
I served in Parliament for over 20 years
I'm very proud to have done so I have
huge admiration for our parliamentary
traditions I'm not going to stand by and
see them disregard it in this fashion
and I think I think if they try to
provoke this thing through I think
there'll be people on I think the
massive demonstrations on the street and
I think it's a very very dangerous thing
to try to do and I don't think they'll
try to do it should we just see James
Gina Miller setting out her store where
she's she claims she's not trying to
stop brexit this is simply a matter of
sovereignty we think that it's beyond
the Prime Minister's powers because
parliamentary sovereignty is actually
the sort of jewel in the constitutional
crown and two bypasses close the doors
of parliament we feel from the advice in
the case we've looked at that the case
law we've looked at that that would be
beyond a prime ministers powers it would
be an abuse of his powers to close
Parliament to get through or to not get
to her to limit the voice of the
representatives that we all elect so the
problem here is a parliament voted by a
majority of 43 against No Deal so
whoever that is Prime Minister is going
to struggle to get a vote
for No Deal the part of the problem we
have is that we have a unwritten
Constitution and this is going to put
the Queen in an extremely difficult
position away be having to decide
whether this should be allowed or not
which is not what we should have an
eponymous democracy what do you think I
agree I completely agree with you
ray joy I thought your intro was
completely spot-on because what we need
to decide is what take back control
means does take back control mean
parliamentary sovereignty or does it
mean that we put in a strong man and an
autocrat and I think that actually if
the Prime Minister whoever that is
decides that a No Deal is the only
option then the only thing to do is
either a people's vote for general
election if you want to push something
through that you think the people want
give it to the people Nick what do you
think do you think that a part of the
next mpq the stock breaks do a question
about junior Miller I am sat here one
week and you told me that you completely
change your mind about Jeanne Miller you
were a strong opponent and now you were
supposed to men just the way she plays I
know that you and Michelle had your
doubts then you voted for brexit
everyone's doubled down but do you think
that it is right or constitutional or
democratic that one man necessarily may
be served with ministers enforces a No
Deal brexit on the country without any
part any approval any popular approval
at all well I would suggest perhaps the
popular approval comes from seventeen
point four million people they voted to
leave no voted to leave they voted to
leave what was an advisory referendum on
watch the game go to Parliament see what
then why would you have a problem us
going back to just double check now we
know what this thing is that that is
exactly what they were voting for surely
you're confident that we would get the
same result again honestly think that
will resolve anything by going back what
is the point what is the because we know
clearly what it is now shall we hear
from someone who's in a likely by this
time next week to be in a far more
senior position regarding all of this
than any of us speaking earlier this
month
Boris Johnson seventeen point four
million people voted to leave it was a
clear clear majority for believe the MPs
acknowledge that and they voted MPs
themselves voted overwhelmingly to
trigger article fifty and to come out of
the EU and now we're in a state where
MPs seemed still to be refusing to enact
the mandate of the people and it's very
difficult racial to argue with any of
them because the MPs did vote to trigger
article 50 and the people did vote as I
do that when the people voted to leave
they were told by the vote leave
campaign that this would not mean
leaving the customers using this would
not mean leaving the single not really
fashion Jesus we mean three hundred
fifty million for the NHS lot of things
we thought it was gonna be party that
ever stands at a general election puts
out a manifest manifesto that's already
a part of traffic we knew they weren't
being lied to and since then we've had a
general election which more than eighty
percent of people voted for parties that
said they would respect the result which
meant we left the we crashed out it
didn't mean that we left with no deal
exiting as with a no deal as crashing
out because actually if people properly
understood what exiting under WTO rules
means and they were able to understand
and prepare and get ready for that and
if you could somehow have a transition
period from both sides into that it
wouldn't be crashing out and I do have
to pick you up Craig when you say it was
an advisory referendum it was so clear
on that leaflet pamphlet thing that we
all received that the government would
have implemented what we decided it was
black and white and it really frustrated
as a business one can ask you okay the
front page of the FT of times today No
Deal will send Britain into recession
that's the Office of Budget
Responsibility which is an independent I
as a businesswoman would you vote for
something if you had a vote that will
see a crashing inward investment
GDP falling four to eight percent
year-on-year weakening we pound right
now
Manufacturing strolling tonsor
construction stalling it's quite a
business with the uncertainty no he
knowing the uncertainty is about the
threat of leaving without a deal the
uncertainties because people haven't
accepted the result and actually
implement some services so that
everybody knows where they stand
that's what I think all before in 22
anyway if your everything happens if
you're a brexit teen you'll be falling
asleep now with this lot trying to
convince you to remain I'm sure sir
you're watching the pledge on Sky News
an oak leg can you really trust what you
hear and see on TV
[Music]